what about educational channel voice
what educational challenge do you guys
watch
oh i mean vsauce is the one that they
haven't they haven't uploaded in a while
but i mean
is it even vsauce anymore because like
he's doing like minefield or mine
yeah i haven't seen he had a channel
called dong do you remember that yeah i
remember
that and then youtube forced him to
change it to like ding yeah
because dong was obviously like i can't
believe that that's awful
are we are we counting like engineering
[ __ ] videos yeah
educational because i feel like
engineering has had like a [ __ ]
resurgence within these past few years
thanks to creators like michael reeves
um william osmond martin and mark rober
and like like i didn't like i wish they
were around
when i was in [ __ ] universal yeah
right because i didn't know engineering
could be cool
until they started making content man i
think i think especially the [ __ ]
posting ones like michael reeves i mean
i found michael reeves when he was doing
like when he was branded as like the
laser guy
yeah his whole he made one video about a
laser pointing in his eye yeah
for like months his channel was like
everything he was the lazy dude
yeah and he was so it's so cool seeing
him blow up and also just making
engineering cool
yeah like william osman and yeah mark
robertson i think the latest video
the latest creator i discovered was a
stuff made here i love stuff
and he's just he's just like someone who
is just
i don't i don't know what it is about
him that like
stands out like even more because he's
not he's not a [ __ ] poster one no no
he's he's like a very serious
engineering one but he just makes these
really cool contraptions
and some of the stuff he makes takes so
much effort
it's it's insane how high the the like
the bar for like
good engineering right yeah the
explosive bat yeah what the [ __ ]
like like he made a baseball bat that
has like four
shells in it yeah when you hit it it
explodes and eject a thing that shoots
the base
basically he basically the concept was
he wanted to make a baseball bat
that anyone could use to like get a home
run right
right like to to like yeah break the
world record for home run and so he
[ __ ] just
[ __ ] puts shotgun shells into this
baseball bat
and he he breaks down his entire process
about
how to make this feasible and it's like
the first the first problem he had to
overcome was like
he he made a baseball bat that worked
but anyone who would use it would
[ __ ] break their arm if they used it
right
and it's like his level or his like
knowledge and level of engineering is
just like on a different [ __ ] scale
fantastic presentation yeah and great
presentation
there's actually a japanese youtuber i i
don't watch many japanese youtubers but
because frankly they're all quite meh
but there's one japanese youtuber who
like blew up recently or
like quite recently who's like kind of
like he's like halfway between
engineering and just absolute
shitpost uh okay
and uh and he does these videos where
it's basically just him having fun just
like a guy who like ejects himself
on like a car yes yeah he he does like
he basically is like uh he was the one
who popularized the
uh if you carve out a watermelon and
then you boil salt water to a thousand
degrees and you pour it in the
watermelon explodes
i who found that he did apparently but
like
the a recent one that he did was like he
was like i love popcorn
so i'm gonna make a i think it was like
a 50 meter long
popcorn container and just fill it up
with popcorn and then
he did that and it's [ __ ] massive and
it's all filled up with popcorn but then
he took it one step further and he
invited his friends and he pranked them
by
making this fake room in his studio
so that the popcorn would fall in as if
it would cave into the house oh my god
and it was [ __ ] insane and and the
videos are so short he just managed to
like condense that [ __ ] into like a five
minutes kind of like it sounds like
david dobrik right she's doing it
yeah it is he just does the most insane
[ __ ] like there was another one where he
like you know
he he wanted to replicate the the force
of someone going into space but
obviously you couldn't afford a rocket
so what he did was he created this
contraption where it would explode
underneath him and it would just ignore
that yeah and he flew like 15 meters
into the air
and like almost broke his neck and he's
just laughing the entire time i'm like
this guy's a [ __ ]
psycho but he's so fun to watch and
japanese youtubers are like
but that's the thing it's it's like he's
a japanese youtuber like he can only
speak japanese and all that but
he just presents things it's so visual
that you don't have to understand what
he's saying to be such an entertaining
video
yeah like we're getting we're now
getting to the point in youtube where to
stand out you need to like
have genuine qualifications and uh
experience behind the stuff you do
because
like some of these a lot of these
creators that we've mentioned can
easily get jobs in the in their field in
their professional field yeah like the
the sushi namin
i think he's only like 18. oh my god
he's just like a [ __ ] wizard engineer
jesus christ
i mean it goes to show that right
because like the quality of the
engineering is like so insane at this
point yeah yeah
like the top channels that doing it are
like oh my god yeah like i have an
engineering degree and i'm like
baffled by some of this absolutely three
years
i have a master's in engineering some of
the stuff they're coming up with is just
like man
this is is this is this what i would
have done if i had stayed in my
engineering course
michael roosev he made the [ __ ]
surgery robot yeah oh yeah
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] i met him as well he
was like the nicest dude ever right
like uh because we were at the anime
awards and he was leaving and we didn't
really get a chance to talk much now
yeah he came over just to say bye to me
like sounds like i was like wow dude
like people don't normally do that
that's really [ __ ] yeah
i mean and and lily peach was super nice
yeah like from what i've seen the
offline tv crew just seemed like just
great
yeah trash taste offline tv collab when
question mark
okay when the world opens when the world
opens up and we can fly to places
although i can fly to places yeah who
the [ __ ] knows
i watch so many [ __ ] educational
channels like obviously like everyone
watches cpg gray
yeah do you guys watch tom scott yeah i
watched tom scott i i'm not subscribed
to tom scott yeah but man
he his videos will not leave my record
he's one of those channels that i just
know because like i don't even need to
subscribe to your channel or two for
them to appear on your resume yeah i i
used to i used to whenever i used to go
to the youtube studio in london
yeah he's always there like just editing
his videos
and i never said hi cause i felt bad
she's not editing but he seems like a
[ __ ]
he seems like a machine i i respect i
respect because i respect his
work because he has like a schedule i
don't know how he's able to upload so
consistently
with like the the amount of videos he
has also corona and he's somehow still
going abroad yeah
like he has like really interesting
ideas so
consistently like here's his video where
where it was about like this video has
x amount of views that just [ __ ]
exactly live
yeah yeah yeah yeah i knew his name was
familiar
red shirt yes
what impresses me the most actually is
how he's able to present his information
with like zero cuts in like without a
script
just just in just in one sentence he
just remembers it he just remembers it
like how does he do that i remember he
did like a dasani video about like
dasani the water bottle
yeah it was like a five minute video did
it all in one take yeah down the street
and i'm like what
like how are you doing this is so
professional it's so good
i'm reading off a script and even i need
like five takes to get one
[ __ ] line sometimes i just love the
memes of like oh i'm here
have you seen those memes right yeah
yeah yeah breaking breaking down the tom
scott yeah
obviously there's kirkus cook
yeah um real life law yeah real life law
i like uh obviously he's smarter every
day as well
yeah yeah um do you guys watch um we've
seen mike boyd the guy like learns
things
like he'll like spend like a week just
learning something
and he won't stop the video until he
does it so like he'll learn how
there's one video where he learned to
shatter glass with his voice
i feel like i've seen this thumbnail
he's everywhere i feel like it's
really good and he just learns like
completely [ __ ] useless skills i know
i know a boy in a band did kind of a
parody of that where he learned to sing
in 30 days oh do you think
yeah yeah that's cool yeah which is
really cool yeah really good videos i
highly recommend it uh there's also
uh [ __ ] like uh casually casually
explained is also kind of similar to it
is it like i
i i i is is he educational or is he mean
do you know do you know
salmonella do you know salmonella he
does like casually explained but
more education because because here's
the thing like i think that's the part
yeah here's his thing like
there's like there's like uh engineering
and what
are educational youtubers and then
there's like casually explained
who are just like i mean the ted what
they say is technically correct right
but uh is anyone actually watching them
to be
like educated
not really no probably not have you
watched george j
forman i do not watch jay formula he
does videos mainly about london
like history of london and stuff and
like it's just so insane
how well produced these videos are i
also met him ages ago
probably doesn't remember because it was
like [ __ ] four years ago uh yeah and
he's just obsessed with london
and uh but his videos are so [ __ ]
well done and they're so funny
and like he'll he'll just do a shot
where he's just in the middle of the
street in london for like two seconds
but he doesn't get a cameraman here to
get there to set it all up it's like
it's insane
wow and it's just all to talk about
london most of the time
i'd highly recommend it uh if you like
just general history about london
fair enough i mean recently like i've
definitely found myself
i used to not watch a lot of the youtube
videos from like the really like big
like corporate channels yeah
i don't really like the corporate
channel yeah you know like i i used to
look at like wyatt and volks channels
and be like uh it's just
like a [ __ ] channel called cheddar
sometimes but i feel just so sad
watching it
okay that that name sounds familiar
because they always do the video like
why new york has big skylines
why electric cars aren't in america it's
like such generic titles of like
i don't know why walmart is big and it's
like every single video is so lifeless
yeah and like it's informative i i would
say
there is one kind of like i'd say
corporation kind of video that i i do
enjoy and i don't know
if this is the name of the channel but
the name of the series is like big great
story
yeah or something like that they
actually have like really cool and
interesting stories i think one of my
favorite videos of them
was like they they they were in japan
and there was this like japanese person
who sells painting made in microsoft
excel
what i haven't seen that yeah so there's
this guy who
there was a japanese guy who just like
he just wanted to express himself of
course but he had zero skills
they do a lot of japan they do do a lot
of stuff a lot of
things in japan but like he had zero
skills like painting and like you know
art skills
so he just started like making pictures
in microsoft excel
and they actually like he he's been
doing it for so long that they
started to become really [ __ ] good
right
and it was just like such a like
uplifting story to just be like it
doesn't really matter
what your tools are now that is a big
great story that is a big great story
it's
a great story they're always super
concise as well they're not too long
it's just great there's also another
story about this [ __ ] soup
that is being like made in thailand or
something like that yeah it's like 50
years old
that's like been boiling for 50 years i
remember i remember watching it and it
was just like
they they didn't [ __ ] wash the place
at all so the oil had been built up so
it's a [ __ ] mountain
next to this massive pot so gross
have you been there i have not been
there you're gonna go back down you go
to town
i'm like if you ever like take us to
thailand which i'm sure will happen
eventually
we really want to go i actually want to
like see if it's good or not